and the impeachment inquiry took center
stage during a sometimes contentious
presidential debate in Atlanta ten
Democrats stood side-by-side for debate
number five last night candidates
sparred over issues like paid family
leave abortion rights and voter
suppression our Ed O'Keefe is in Atlanta
at good morning so what were your big
takeaways from last night well Toni they
also discussed things like health care
climate change and foreign policy but it
all began with an issue that the
candidates rarely discuss on the
campaign trail that impeachment saga
back in Washington we have a criminal
living in the White House the candidates
were all in agreement over the house and
Pietschmann inquiry I learned something
about these impeachment trials
I learned number one that Donald Trump
doesn't want me to be the nominee but
senator Bernie Sanders said it shouldn't
consume the party we can deal with
Trump's corruption we also have to stand
up for the working families of this
country and so the candidates dove into
issues rarely discussed on a debate
stage including child care is one of the
first things we do six months paid
family leave is meant to and is designed
to adjust to the reality of women's
lives today
it was also discussion of whether
implementing government-run health care
is too politically risky
let's bring as many people in and get as
much help to the American people as we
can as fast as we can it couldn't pass
the United States Senate right now with
Democrats it couldn't pass the House the
candidates sparred over who had the best
experience to be President
women are held to a higher standard
otherwise we could play a game called
name your favorite woman president which
we can't do because it is all been
Washington experience is not the only
experience that matters there's more
than a hundred years of Washington
experience on this stage and where are
we right now as a country South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Buda judge has made
recent gains and early State polling but
he still has a problem with support
among black voters the question has to
be where you been and what are you gonna
do
I completely agree and I welcome the
challenge of connecting with black
voters in America who don't yet know me
former Vice President Joe Biden remained
a popular target this week I hear him
literally say that I don't think we
should legalize marijuana
I thought you might've been high when
you said it
I've been tried to highlight his support
especially among black voters but not
without some I know who I am
three former chairs of the Black Caucus
the only black American woman that ever
been elected to the United States Senate
a whole range of people
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
for many of the candidates the campaign
the campaigning continues today here in
Georgia the Peach State is one that
Democrats hope to win next year but that
would require big turnout here in the
Atlanta area from there the campaign
scatters especially back to Iowa where
there's just 74 days left until the
first in the nation caucus tarika all
right ed O'Keefe force in Atlanta Thank
You ed